[Music]
it's Argentina's Independence Day and
for the government there was another
reason to celebrate
[Music]
pipeline that will transform Argentina's
energy sector by transporting gas from
Baka muerta one of the largest Shale oil
and gas reserves in the world located in
the Patagonia region is
it's the beginning of the change in
Argentina's economic and energy Matrix
because 65 of our energy is thermal and
gas is our transitional energy
we are no longer going to import gas we
are going to use gas from our subsoil
the almost 600 kilometer pipeline was
built in less than 12 months the
pipeline is seen as an accomplishment of
economy Minister and now presidential
candidate Sergio masaku personally
oversaw this project Masa and the
peronis party are facing a tough
re-election bid this year mostly because
of Argentina's deep economic crisis
Argentina is struggling with very high
inflation and over 40 billion dollar
debt with the IMF that is struggling to
pay back and assured your foreign
currency
the pipeline will allow the country to
save at least 2 billion dollars in gas
Imports in 2023 a figure that will
likely increase in the future
the pipeline will bring gas to the areas
where there is none or where it is used
more intensely it will reduce the
dollars that leave the country to pay
for imports and will increase the
dollars we get when we're able to export
it
in October argentinians will be choosing
a new president analysts say that
whoever wins the vote will face tough
choices to solve the imbalances in
Argentina's economy
the political power of the next
president won't be in Congress it will
be in the social permit he or she will
achieve if people can understand what he
or she is doing if public opinion can
Transit the pain of the adjustments that
need to be made
dollar
the new pipeline is a positive move in a
country that is struggling with around
114 percent inflation in the past year
and it's a political victory for a
government that has been unable to
address the one issue that concerns
argentinians the most there is